maybe it's not the majority of men but
it's starting to become a movement [__]
you go away go find your women wherever
you want if you're not satisfied I don't
know what to tell you if you want a
woman who barely even speaks English and
just has to suck your dick up go for it
I think men would actually prefer that
because then we would like talk less
I think I'm 10 my girlfriend thinks I'm
a 10 I'm a 10.
I wish I was on this panel can you
imagine I would just I would just go in
and I would say ladies let's be honest
Miami or London which women are hotter
it's just it's just I know everyone has
their panties in a bunch right now about
how I've licked my own excrement before
but I will
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I'm going to be
reacting to Modern women are Furious as
men check out abroad for romance before
I start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
and let's get a thousand likes on this
tweet um okay so this is alienated TV
manosphere channel I know everyone
panties and a bunch right now about how
I've licked my own excrement before but
I will say I do not do that anymore I
have learned and if I do do it I make
sure it's clean usually what the [__] if
you're a guy that's looking for a girl
that's 5 11 almost 30.
it's pretty funny but pretty damaged got
a great personality I'm right here
that's not gonna happen I was just
thinking I'm 5 11 too just your friendly
reminder that if he's not literally
obsessed with you remove we hate the men
that are obsessed with us can we stop
pretending like we want these men that
are just obsessed with us we want a man
with a lot of [__] going on um and I
think deep down it's because we know we
really aren't worth that much like men
used to be obsessed with men I mean it
kind of worked out but it like made
sense to be obsessed with them then like
they were close they were they were
virgins right they had like their own
cookbook their whole life was dedicated
to their man right their whole life was
dedicated to making their man happy now
I'm not saying that's the ideal right
but it made a little more sense and the
women accepted it more they stayed
married right you you got you know um
what's the that movie The The Notebook
where that dude was threatening to like
to fall off of the the sir the uh the
what's it called the circle thing the
car at carnivals the ferris wheel the
ferris wheel he was threatening to throw
himself off the ferris wheel if she
didn't go on a date with him now that's
major zimping but that woman fell in
love with him but it made sense because
back then the women were in shape they
didn't sleep around
um they were just better all together
just of something I've had this theory
for a while but it just clicked again
after I heard what she said
um I actually think I think I've said
this to you before I actually think that
back in the day
um obviously human beings in general
were more
consensuous or whatever that word is
about I don't know if I'm using it right
but like we were more self-aware we kind
of knew understood objective reality so
I think back in the day women
um saying things that they didn't want
as what they want as a way to screen men
because if a woman says like oh I want
this this does that and then all the men
are rushing to come and give that to her
oh my gosh then that way she knows that
these are the men to scream because he's
just gonna do whatever I say but I think
because of social media and
modernization and feminism and all the
confusion that we have in society today
I think women have forgotten the power
that they have in quotes but the biology
is still there so a lot of women don't
even know why they do a lot of things
now but it's it's still days it's just
the way men we do some things I wouldn't
even know why but
it's actually a good huh M frog
in front I have no idea it's basically
guys going to other countries to find
women that are more feminine and
submissive and more traditional more
attractive
lady inflation is a term which describes
the increase in price we have to pay for
lower value women
have to work 20 times harder than their
grandfathers to secure women who are 10
times worse than what their grandmothers
were
the perceived increased valuation of a
western Modern Woman believing she's a
10 when she's actually a five has left
many men with no choice other than to
leave the dating Market entirely or to
vote with their passport I have pretty
high self-confidence and I don't care
what other people think so attend I'm a
10. 10. I feel like a 10. I'm a 10 and
everybody's a 10 if they feel like
they're 10. what I think I'm a 10. my
girlfriend thinks but you see it goes
this goes back to egalitarian like when
women get into power we we go more
towards equality rather than hierarchy
not 110 was seen right now wait we
should wait wait let's rate them
together let's rate them let's see if
yeah because it's interesting because
we've talked about this how guys and
girls have like different ratings let me
go first let me go first so I would rate
her yeah
I don't care what other people think so
attend this is just based off of face
obviously ah wait wait hold on gotta
stop it I have pretty high
self-confidence and I don't care what
other people think so attend uh that's
it damn it I have pretty high
self-confidence and I don't care what
other people think so a 10. I'm a 10. I
was gonna say five I'll give her six
because she looks slim yeah yeah you're
right the last one six this one five
this is an actual five five I feel like
a ten six no six I think six yes by the
way not all sixes are the same yeah I'd
like to say I agree yeah like that's
what I was like
yeah no because you could have a strong
six or a week the way I do it in my head
is I don't give sevens right so oh yeah
we're gonna do Kevin Samuel's skill no
seven six is cute eight you could get a
modeling contract so I think of like six
is cute eight is the prettiest girl in a
small town nine is the prettiest girl in
a big city or like one of the you know
ten is damn near perfect number 10 and
everything I'd still give her a sec I
think she's cute yeah she kind of I
don't know about she kind of looks
I think one maybe one no two two ten my
girlfriend thinks I'm a ten I'm a ten I
know I give out two though she's really
fat yeah and I on top of that's the
first thing but on top of that did like
the nose ring and all of that yeah yeah
yeah even that was like the hoop
earrings kind of put me off for the one
girl I just don't like that yeah for
guys we don't look at we don't really
look at those yeah just look at the face
itself yeah it kind of looks like a
month yeah 11. I look in the mirror oh I
this this side
[Music]
I've been wearing that far off yeah yeah
yeah no but we we go off when body
starts to get involved that's what I've
noticed because me I'll look at the face
like cause I'm a chick you know I'm not
I think I think I'm very you start to go
off in the higher numbers in the lower
numbers we'll pretty much be around the
same but once it starts like so like I
think men and women actually find the
most attractive people different really
yeah because you know what one people
they always say like um like some guys
don't agree with me with Margot Robbie I
think Margot Robbie is like a nine now I
know I see the difference
I think she's prettier than the
prettiest girl in a small town for me
anyways no but now I think she can be
the prettiest girl in a small town I
think she'd be one of the prettiest in a
big city like in London
be the prettiest girl we've had on the
show in London yeah but that's nothing
but if you're talking about from what do
you think she would be the prettiest
girl in Miami well yeah but she'd be one
of them I think I think I'm told is
blaming your lack of relationship
success on an entire nation of women
it's very successful in England very
very successful but I noticed that every
time I saw a beautiful woman and when
when to talk to her where are you from
old Sweden oh Russia there's no views
for women in the U.S yeah there are for
sure most of a lot of them are foreign
in London and it's just comparatively
there are way more in Russia
the gentleman is making the
generalization that British modern women
have become entitled overweight and are
lacking in femininity they're therefore
comparatively speaking not as
marriageable as some of the women in
other countries
rather than listen to his Viewpoint and
exploring it what we see is instant
shame insult guilt and the need to be
right at this point we're used to male
honesty being viewed as misogyny
but it's rare to see a model yeah I
think instead of whining about men
getting their passports we should take
notes that's what I think all right look
it look it I think
is doing better than you you should take
notes and learn from them so you know if
the if the West the non-western women
are stealing our men let's ask why are
they stealing our men and maybe try to
improve in those areas because a man of
being entitled and racist because he
prefers women from other countries when
the debate is lost slander becomes the
tool of the loser yes exactly exactly do
you think there were any other reasons
why you weren't particularly successful
with British women when you were very
successful like I said but you've just
said that most of the women that you
were attracted to were foreign so you
know telling women that you're
potentially going to date that yeah look
I'm sorry yeah you're entitled
overweight
may not may not be the most successful
chat up line it's not one I would
recommend this is like a process of my
experience I was in the UK until 2009
then I traveled a lot I've been to 60
countries you know I went to Brazil
they're very nice I went to Scandinavia
Denmark's got very beautiful women but
when I went to Russia I found the whole
package
we see more attempts to shame and beat
him into an emotional reaction it was
funny I actually support the passport
Bros but a guy was I saw this thing I
was like
I was like you girl from another country
and bring her back because if she's
willing to if she's not loyal to her
country who's to say she'll be loyal to
you
once a man reacts emotionally he's
usually lost the argument because it's
over emoting will be used to lambast him
I'd say there's a high probability You
Should Never Wrestle with a pig because
you'll both get dirty and the pig enjoys
it
to many interviewers on TV a discussion
is not usually an exchange of
information rather it's a platform to
rile and push an agenda that's really
messed up and it's no surprise that he
finds Russian women to be more desirable
it's a part of the world where hyper
individualism and the ephinous movement
have never fully taken hold you're just
petting like a really dangerous like
star
s go in and I would say ladies just be
look it I'm from America and I'm sorry
the women are better looking in America
too now now before you attack my looks
which is always what they'll go for
let's just like let's be honest Miami or
London which women are hotter it's just
it's just easy it's just like and I'm
from Chicago I'll say the Miami chicks
are hotter than the Chicago chicks and I
am from Chicago we get six months in the
winter to hide the blubber we just look
at when you when it's hot year round the
women are just better looking because
the clothes are off you know what I mean
and I would go in on this panel and I I
would tell them to stop shaming him for
this and really we should take notes as
women and learn the beauty
um that is just so damaging for women
and men complain to Victoria's Secret
but stop complaining to the men and
maybe instead of whining to the men
about their opinion ask is it true is it
true and that's the other thing I am so
tired of describing the problem and
being attacked for describing what the
problem is when really we should be mad
at is the women making the problem we
should be mad at the women and only fans
we should be mad at this entitlement but
instead they they make him the scapego
don't make me the scapegoat anyone that
says anything that's true human
aesthetic judgment is a complicated
mixture of genetic cultural and
objective factors but there are
stereotypical Beauty markers such as
health fertility and symmetry to name a
few deal whether you babies the maxim
beauty is in the eye of the beholder is
largely incorrect wishful thinking
doesn't change things in the real world
what we're seeing here is a modern woman
who doesn't appreciate it when men have
preferences that might exclude her from
consideration men do not need to have a
preference of preferences are for the
girls I want a bunch of beta orbiters
and Sims falling over me when basic apps
are able to understand stereotypical
aesthetic appeal it's clear that an
agreed broad standard of beauty exists I
grew up with the dog filter on Snapchat
this is what I look like in real life oh
my gosh you see that look at how
different she looks this filter gave me
little ears this is what I look like in
real life how crazy but that's what I
mean why these apps make us delusional
where we think we look like this and
she's cute you know what I mean she's
cute but I'm just like this is so
different and now you don't think so not
a six this filter gave me the pillars
this is what I look like in real life
hmm
this is my what would you rate her it's
with a ring light on The Bold glamor
filter this is my face with a sock this
is why okay this is why this is what
irritates me women women will attack me
but yet they have three filters on a
whole cake full of makeup fake hair a
BBL lip fill or Botox where and it
really shows I'm sorry if that's what
you're spending your money on it really
shows narcissism and vanity yes and
Vanity's a sin yes it is her and a ring
light no ring light no filter and then
this is my face oh what look at the
before and after no filter and then this
is these in real life oh my God and this
even extends to body Beauty I didn't
even know you could edit videos the real
healthy me wow that's
upside getting scary and even with AI
now it's only going to get worse of
course some people will prefer the
unfiltered look but to suggest that a
stereotypical view of beauty is damaging
is an attempt to rationalize a way of
you she doesn't like we're toppling the
patriarchy there's no point in bothering
some people with facts because they've
already made up their mind well Richard
we have three English women here uh
Brazil are they all fat entitled stupid
I mean what oh my gosh appears why are
you simping so hard
um Brazil are they all I would say well
I mean one of them kind of is entitled
and I would say this is what I would say
it does this isn't a personal attack but
when we take the average English woman
she's uh I don't know I think they're a
little thinner than the US so 160 pounds
um they're sleeping around there and
this isn't this isn't me you know trying
to you know shame anybody but it's
objectively the Russian women are way
better looking I understand why he's
going there I mean what and here we see
a Clueless interviewer who's lacking in
intellectual Integrity attempting to act
as the White Knight of righteousness
what he's constructed a straw man
argument because at no point did the
interviewee apply his views to all
English women or ever use the words fat
or stupid men like this are
unfortunately one of the many tentacles
that make up the Matrix
it is hugely attractive men who are
highly intelligent and want to have
successful committed relationships how
come these incredible men are not
finding women here in the UK the next
section of the video gets messy because
there's a lot of crosstalk however I did
some research and the same man appeared
in a British national newspaper talking
about this subject
he said that British modern women want a
guy who's successful good looking and
chivalrous even though they don't have
much to offer in return
he also says that American modern women
are massively let down by their loud
often unintelligent and entitled
demeanor would you date a bus driver you
would you date if he owns the bus that's
the problem yeah you know what I was
thinking about she's a way bigger loser
than the guy that owns the bus because
the guy that are not not owns the bus
that works the bus driver because that
guy could still have a family she can't
she's 39. but it's like we were allowed
to live in delusion because we get to
like how much work has she had done
that's I don't care like I refuse to get
this Botox lip filler all this [__] like
because it's just like it doesn't allow
you to be like happy with the way you
are because you're constantly trying to
like attain a younger version of
yourself and it doesn't allow you to
like live with the consequences that are
supposed to come with women as age when
you ate like you're supposed to be more
humble you're supposed to move
differently than when you're a kid but
because we can like play pretend that
we're younger we we get to like act like
kids till we're 45 and menopause hits us
standards and the criteria that we use
to measure men is off for who we are as
women and who they are in this Society
this is another example of Lady
inflation I think I'm still relatively
young I guess but I'm 40.
regarding Russian women he says they're
ladylike accomplished intelligent and
have traditional Family Values these
qualities are crucial because it's a
woman's mindset that'll raise your child
not her beauty you're suggesting that
there's a cheats way to being confident
and right with yourself and that cheats
way is to just move abroad
so men exploring their options and
moving abroad to find desirable women
who are more likely to appreciate them
is now cheating the system unfortunately
you're not very bright and women do this
don't they go to like Africa and like
marry the men there yeah it's like women
do the same thing some men have decided
that Western modern women are not worth
the investment they've decided to cut
their losses so that they can come out
on top in another country
does the effort of pursuing a western
Modern Woman outweigh the reward no
no because often a cost-benefit analysis
will determine that they represent too
much risk and yield too lower return
why do you think so many men are
traveling overseas to find wives in
other countries men are traveling
overseas to find wives why I'm right
here I'm single no I want to be married
see women traveling overseas they're
traveling overseas to countries that
have less money and less education it's
because they want a woman who is
dependent on them for their livelihood
for their resources to have a good life
and I don't think that that is a good
thing accountability is a modern woman's
Kryptonite logic is her arch nemesis and
deflection is her Ultimate Defense
not because men want a woman who's
dependent on them for their livelihood
or their resources it's because marriage
in the west is a raw deal because it's
not marriage it's like it's not marriage
significant risk to the man's future
smart men don't get married it's
essentially A Primitive ownership of the
man by the wife Western Society is
gynocentric in the ways that government
will make a special effort to
accommodate women even at the expense of
men marriage should not feel like a pact
with the devil yeah that sounds good
what do you think the reason that men
are not like sad satisfied with the
women in this country tree and they're
looking elsewhere outside I'm satisfied
with the women in this country not
really no where are you getting this off
of well passport Bros and uh then 90 Day
Fiance I mean obviously there's a
movement that isn't that is the outlier
that is the it's like we can give so
many examples of let's like we have
fresh and fit the women in Miami we have
um Rolo doing a show in Vegas we have
um uh whatever in California it's like
we can show so many examples of the
problem and in places from all over the
world and yet yet they will just say oh
it's not all women are like that those
are just exceptions you just get crazy
people on your show it's like no well
exception to the rule I don't think the
majority of men are not happy with women
in this country it's not really an
outlier in America the 2020 National
marriage rate fell to 5.1 for every 1
000 people its lowest level in over 120
years you better check yourself before
you wreck yourself American modern women
are prioritizing careers travel and
leisure activities over building
families when this is combined with
women's ever increasing unrealistic
standards for what they look for in a
man it's no surprise that men are
looking abroad
how else is the average man supposed to
start a family maybe it's not the
majority of men but it's starting to
become a movement [__] you go away go
find your women wherever you want
to tell you if you want a woman who
barely even speaks English and just has
to suck your go for it
I think men would actually prefer that
because then we would like talk less
she's like you they're like you don't
want a woman that like even speaks your
language no matter like yes that
actually sounds like a good solution I
don't even know what she's saying it's
like you can just watch her look pretty
is that women like this will always
shift the diagnostic crosshairs from
themselves onto men to avoid being a
target for scrutiny
for every alpha female born a cat gets a
new home but it's almost like if we're
to even look at this logically what do
women think men would actually pick a
woman that doesn't talk at all or a
woman that is always nagging we already
know that Common Sense doesn't really
yeah so I mean it's fine
and many men would happily be with a
traditional woman that could not speak
English over a modern woman that could
men that travel abroad simply want a
wife who'll positively contribute to his
life and the view that women from other
countries cannot speak English is obtuse
foolishly arrogant and avoid of
introspection
on a lot of the men I know that go
overseas to find wives are not great
dudes
can you be more specific yeah they're
pervy
that's another thing we shame male
sexuality by calling them perverts yet
we do not feem shame female sexuality
when a woman is sexual it's empowering
imagine if men walked around in Speedos
the way women walk around in bongs like
we weaponize their sexuality against
them even though we can't live without
it we can't live without their attention
so it's kind of like we're like we're
it's interesting we're like we're gonna
be half naked and then when you respond
we're gonna shame you for responding
good example of why passport Brothers
exist many modern women feel like
they're entitled to make blanket
generalizations which are offensively
directed at men
terms like creep and pervy are regularly
thrown around by way of saying they find
an average man doing something they
dislike to be unattractive strange and
unpleasant nobody bats an eyelid at
openly sexist language like mansplaining
but there'd be outrage if women were
told to stop shinagging in all these
comments I'm hearing how you are not
going to tell your sons to marry how you
are happier being single how you would
rather be a passport brother and go to a
different country to find a wife
obviously she's referring to the men who
are lucky enough to even have a
relationship with their sons
when the nuclear family was the norm and
women weren't financially incentivized
to raise a child alone the chance of a
boy having a gainful bond with his
father was greater God damn right and
why would a father not suggest that his
son at least consider going to another
country to find a wife given the lack of
good options in the west now while I
empathetically deeply understand your
rationalization to this conclusion
believe me I do her heart's in the right
place but the well-fed will never
understand the hungry it's wrong on so
many levels because at the same time you
guys are asking how we fix our society
and how we fix our culture to many men
short of sending the asteroid society
and culture can't be fixed no if you ask
modern women what they put to the table
where they should fix it
yeah did you fix it you can even provide
a coherent answer they want to marry a
wealthy superhero yet offer little in
return
there is a
they took women out of the home it
should show you the importance of having
a woman there just like the importance
of having a father in the home if the
key component to detrimentalizing our
society and our culture as a whole in
America is to remove the wife and the
mom from the home then the answer is to
bring her back in inconceivable there
are many reasons for the incentivization
of women being removed from the home so
a report came out from Morgan Stanley
that suggested that by the year 2030
about 45 of women between the ages of 25
to 44 are going to be single and if you
look at different conversations based
upon the study there was this emphasis
on the Shi economy basically the rise of
an economy where women are getting into
more positions of power getting into
more positions into corporate world
specifically into white collar positions
things of that nature and this goes back
to my earlier point one of the reasons I
do think there is a big push for women
to delay marriage to not be married at
all and I have kids at all is because
again that gives women more time and
access to work and slave away for these
corporations well and and you know I I
think I feel like single women spend
more than when they're with the guy
because the guy's like no you can't
spend the credit a thousand dollars on
the credit card no
and how do you bring women back in that
have been raised to be strong and
independent
look at this clip with modern women
revealing their body counts
um probably like 300 something she's the
Village bicycle when's it like 50 50.
okay I'm also at 50. Kiko body count men
and women are
modern women with impulse control issues
don't even know how to be desirable to
men in the long term everyone's had a
ride if the maxim a woman's body count
is inversely proportional to her ability
to commit is true how do we get these
women off the streets and back into the
home exactly
it's impossible
hyper promiscuity has become normalized
and few men want a woman who's been ran
through more times than a yellow light
that's building your house on Sand has
never been a good idea do you qualify
for high value guy you said yes and I'm
asking you what factors make you
qualified uh did I make calls okay so
high value for me would be like well you
can see her boobs out from a mile away
what high volume man is going to take us
seriously I don't know I have my same
values because if not it's never going
to work and what are those values yeah
what values does a woman with a sleeve
and her tits out have because and this
is another thing I just had a very nice
thought because these women keep saying
well um I have it I can have a tattoo I
can do all of this I can dress however I
want but that doesn't mean I can't teach
my kids right okay so how can you teach
your kids the right thing you say one
thing to them and they look at you and
then when they go out in society the
people they see that look at you are
doing the opposite so it's you're almost
kind of confusing your kids from the
very beginning because kids are smarter
than people think
I am actually disgusted and appalled by
how many mothers we've had come on the
show and I look at their Instagram and
it's full of thirsty straps I could
actually disgusts me because I'm like
you have especially the ones with sons
I'm like why are you why are you posting
this stuff when you have a son and it
kind of speaks to society just how like
selfish the average modern like chick is
um not not just you know not all
obviously but it's like it actually
disgusts me because I'm like why are
these [__] half naked on Instagram
with children like I can't even imagine
growing up my mom was doing that I'll
just like agree with me
she's correct about Partners needing the
same values or it'll never work but
demanding that a man just agree with her
isn't a value it's more an indication of
someone with a high conflict personality
who's self-absorbed and likely to
exhibit controlling Behavior do exactly
as I say controlling Behavior can also
be a symptom of several personality
conditions such as histrionic borderline
and narcissistic personality disorder
fact s this is something all men should
be aware of because a relationship with
this type of individual is often more
challenging than most yes do you think a
successful guy that has this stuff
together cares about you having money
yourself no actually and so why would
you list that out as a quality
some of the qualities that make a woman
desirable would be things like Integrity
cooperativeness humility and
selflessness these would be the
antithesis of the requirement that a man
just agree with her oh my God the things
that you're supposed to perform on being
a lady being a good dutiful girlfriend
you said that you're gonna you could do
it but you're not gonna always
this is one of the biggest drawbacks to
dating modern women the practice of
conditional or selective femininity
women like this will hold their
femininity hostage and only release it
if the man acts accordingly subvert the
patriarchy femininity has become a
luxury in the west and is scarcity wow I
never thought of it like that they're
using femininity as a weapon will only
be feminine when you do what I say or
act how I want you to act and that's
what I realized to all these dating
things where they're like you know you
have to hold out for 90 days you have to
like it like you you only get what you
accept or like allow or something like
even that even that phrase allow implies
that you can control men but it's like
the men that that [__] works on you
don't want you in the and the
relationship is doomed because the woman
is leading it that's what I was gonna
say it's kind of counterintuitive like a
real masculine man is not going to be
controlled by your shenanigans so you
doing that is actually pushing like
you're reducing your chances actually
getting the money you say you want it's
rarer than titanium gold and diamonds as
much as the Puppet Masters has put in to
break us as a family unit and as a
society we need to fix it and it
absolutely cannot be fixed without the
help of men sadly men have been
completely destroyed by this feminist
movement what God damn right the Puppet
Master does not like smart inquiring
individuals it only wants NPCs with
limited programming to lead around with
their eyes and ears closed as well as
their brains devoid of useful knowledge
an MPC that's impossible their
appeasement is easily met with bread and
circuses but I also don't want to shame
women and I want to bring them back home
not a great plan you can't have your
cake and eat it too it's well known that
if you want to make a modern woman angry
you tell her the truth which often
involves an element of shaming shame and
I can't do that alone we need help from
men what can the average man do when
women have no interest in them this
might be a particular Bell that can't be
unrun an average attractive male on
Tinder gets swiped less than one percent
of the time and there's three men on
Tinder for every one woman so you've
distilled it you've taken out one of the
key components of mating Dynamics and
that is Vibe humor body language
pheromones the ability to be quite
frankly a little bit persistent in the
pursuit of a romantic relationship Bingo
it's also impossible to communicate
confidence on mine which can be a man's
greatest asset bummer and women have so
many options with online dating it
allows for the undesirable to become
picky am I living in a nightmare right
now you're very right about the way we
use language it's quite weird the way we
have certainly been programmed to almost
fight against ourselves so when they say
shaming when you shame a woman can you
actually shame someone isn't shame felt
internally wow that's so true you can't
shame someone you can tell the truth and
they confuse him about the truth
yeah of course because if you're online
if you lie about me I'm not why will I
be ashamed you can't shame someone I'll
at you in it I'll at you no no yeah okay
you can't shame someone you can tell the
truth truth and they can feel shame what
you're saying is a lie how why would I
just like if you said yeah well it's
like when they say I don't know it's
like even when they insult me it's like
I don't care exactly and if if for
instance they say like um someone calls
a woman a [__] and you know the way
women say well well we we don't care
this other if you really don't care then
why why are you ashamed about being
called a [__] right you should be happy
since that's what you wanted to do wow
wow that's so interesting yeah because
shame has to I actually think shame
comes from God because yeah because it's
like why it's something you feel
internally this inflated sense of sexual
market value is neither good for men nor
women nor society as a whole because
people will stop having children we have
no third place anymore no places to meet
people aren't going to bars they aren't
Sports League they aren't going to
church they aren't even going to work so
it gets distilled down to very one or
two dimensional attributes and the
reality is women are much choosier than
men and they can apply those screens and
they allocate all of their attention to
a small number of men this is before we
even mention that there are a lot of
fake profiles gold diggers and sugar
babies on dating apps stop wasting my
time it's like fishing in the sewer and
besides the apps are designed to be
useless yes they make their money
through advertising and charging hopeful
Romantics for premium features
it's in their best interest for daters
to Wade through a wasteland of endless
swiping only to be rewarded with no
matches how many of us have said I know
a ton of great single women they can't
find a date that's not true they can't
find a date they can't find a man they
find economically or emotionally viable
he's out of line but he's right this
comes back to Lady inflation modern
women overvaluing themselves in the
dating Market I'm a 10 and everybody's a
10 if they feel like they're 10. here's
a pertinent question for the ladies that
are holding out for an economically
attractive man do you look like the
equivalent of the money he makes oh my
God the practice of open hypergamy like
this has been summarized as the high
heels effect in the last 40 years more
women have graduated from college than
men and they're not interested in
meeting with non-college graduates if
this continues what will Society look
like when Blue Collar men fully Embrace
going abroad to find wives imagine this
next clip but on a society-wide scale
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah okay guys
um this was funny I liked this video
um yeah this is you know the effects of
the culture and you know of women just
being able to do everything ourselves
you know
um but let me know what you guys think
in the comments let me know if you have
any other videos you want me to react to
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and I'll talk to you next
time